Hey guys, how's it going it's Justine and today, we are chatting about all things Apple
Event more specifically the new iPhone X which is not actually called iPhone X. It's called iPhone 10 here
It is the iPhone 10. It was officially announced today, and I've got it in my hand
This is a white version, and there's also a space gray version, and this thing is absolutely beautiful.
We're at the home screen here it is
Man It has such an awesome feel to it
This is the space gray. I got a chance to go to the Apple event this year
And it was by far one of the most incredible experiences
Not only because it was my first time ever going to an Apple Keynote
But it was held at the Steve Jobs theater, and this was the first time that this theater has ever been used for anything
It's official the Steve Jobs theater is directly behind me
and
This is my first Apple event ever and to walk in to the Steve Jobs theater up to the doors and see Steve Wozniak standing
there
Was the coolest thing ever it was also one of the first times the people outside of Apple have seen Apple Park have seen their
New campus have seen inside the new Apple Visitor Center where there's a retail store
I buy something what if I could buy things here? Can you buy things here?
Well, I did a little bit of shopping, but a little bit. Oh, yeah, just a little whatever Mac
I'm getting a nice chai latte
And they have this amazing augmented reality feature they have a massive table that weighs 11,000 pounds yes
11,000 and when you look at it with just your normal basic eyes you don't really see much of anything
But when you use their augmented reality app you can get an inside look at the entire Apple part
It's also really interactive so you can swipe up on this little side screen, and it'll show you morning tonight
What it looks like you can also take off the roof which was quite a surprise
Aside from that we are here to chat about the new iPhone which is called the iPhone Ted not the iPhone X
Unfortunately the iPhone 10 is not gonna be available right away pre-orders will be starting on October 27th
And they will ship on November 3rd starting price
Nine hundred and ninety nine
dollars
Worth it out of all of the rumors that I have seen the number one thing is that I am so glad that did not
Come true. Is that blush copper gold color?
I was not a fan of it, and I really just had this feeling there's one thing
I know Apple is not gonna make that color a reality and thankfully it did not because the iPhone 8 comes in this amazing
beautiful
Gold color so before we get too ahead of ourselves
There were three new phones that were announced today number one the iPhone X comes in two different color variations
There's a silver and a Space Gray the sizing options for these is only two
And it was rumored that there was gonna be a 512 gig, but there's not there's only a 64 and a 256
I've already made my decision and I'm
Definitely a hundred percent getting the silver
I think it's so beautiful
And it kind of reminds me of the original iPhone
Next up is the iPhone 8 now technically this would be the 7s if we were kind of following in the footsteps of previous
Namings of iPhones the size and form factor of the eight is pretty much
Just like the iPhone 7 and iPhone 7 plus the biggest how many
friends of the new iPhone 8 is the new color that they have and it is a
Beautiful gold color rolls gold is one of my favorite colors. That's my favorite
type of jewelry to wear and in the past they had a rose gold which was more of a pink and then they had a
Gold, which was almost too gold it was more of a yellow, so this gold is the perfect marriage of the two I mean
It's just the perfect gold color that I could ask for like if I were to make this phone the color that I wanted it
To be it's this color, I've owned eight pre-orders will be starting on September 15
And they will start shipping on September 22nd so set your alarms add it to your iCal prepare yourself for pre-order day
So this is kind of cool you basically
Find your spot on the table. It's not real
The iPhone 10
It's in my hand
I've got a little bit of hands-on with it and the
Craziest thing is the phone is much smaller than a 7 plus, but yet the screen because it's a full OLED screen
Which they are calling it a super Retina display? I love it every time they were saying super retina in the keynote
I was just I would die no aren't super to me is very very funny so followed by Retina super right now
It just had me what actually laughing out loud
I think a lot of people who thought that the plus phones were too big
But the smaller phones are too small this iPhone 10 is the perfect marriage of those two you're losing
No screen real estate, but yet you have a much smaller phone the display looks
Beyond incredible its edge to edge, which means there is no touch ID so Justine
How are we gonna use our phones with no touch ID how are we gonna unlock it?
How are we gonna do anything?
How are we gonna return to home pretty simple you can add a passcode of course or you can use face ID you can use?
Face ID and passcode at the same time just again
That was it you just unlocked it do it again. Yeah, let's yeah, let's see it
But if you're familiar with any type of facial recognition software, it's very simple
There's really not much you have to do you just hold your phone up look at it
And when it recognizes you it unlocks your phone face ID is enabled by a true def camera
It's super simple to set up
I watched this guy set it up in just a few seconds it projects and analyzes more than
30,000 invisible dots to create a very precise depth map of your face, and I watched this happen in person
I watched this guy set it up, and then I watched him unlock his phone immediately
One of the biggest concerns with face ID is what if somebody else has my same face will I be able to use a photo?
How does this all work?
is it safe one of the things that they really stressed in a keynote is whether you get a haircut you wear glasses put a
Hat on grow a beard for instance face ID knows your face
This is far more
Secure than touch ID I've been using facial recognition for a while on my samsung galaxy s 8 and my Microsoft studio
So I'm pretty familiar with it, but watching this whole thing in action was really cool
So you basically just hold your phone out looks good
Oh shoot
Sorry, you need his face, and then you can swipe up to unlock your phone
But my biggest question when I saw this in action was oh wait how do I access control center?
They solved that by now swiping down for control center
Which will probably take a little bit of getting used to but even in this short little bit of hands-on time that I had with
It I got used to it
Really quick so a face ID you'll be able to do all the things that you did with touch ID you'll be able to unlock
Your phone and you'll be able to use Apple pay something that I'm pretty excited about and I think anybody who takes selfies will be
Excited about you can now take portrait photos using the front-facing camera portrait mode allows you to take really
Incredible photos that make it look like it was taken by a professional
The blurred out background really adds to that effect, and there's something else that they also announced. It's a new feature in portrait mode
It's called portrait lighting
it's really kind of crazy inside because
Photographers you guys are gonna be out of a job now because everyone's just gonna be doing everything with their iPhones
I mean Instagram models
This is taking it all to a whole new level hashtag no filter
But hashtag portrait lighting hashtag portrait mode hashtag is this my face is this my body. I'm not even sure I've been in reality
That's the new reality
So because of these cameras can sense depth you're able to make changes on the fly so here's an example of using the stage light
Mono filter this is in the new portrait lighting filters
There's natural light
studio light contour light
Stage light and this stage light mono which pretty much turns the whole background to a nice black
And it looks like it was shot in an actual studio
One of the other rumors that did not come true was the fact that the iPhone X would be us PC and this was something
That I was really looking forward to I have so many USBC cords, but I also have so many lightning cables
It's fine. I can wait a little bit longer
They also announced a wireless charging which is something that I've been looking forward to for quite a while
They also introduced this little guy. This is the air power so with this power charging mat
You can just lay your devices down on it, and they will charge wirelessly
It'll charge the new iPhone the series 3 watch and the new air pods. I got a few tweets where people were like well
What if I want to charge my phone and use it?
Same time well, then you plug it in you don't have to wirelessly charge
They did it not some other partners who were going to be making other wireless charging devices so stay tuned for those I know they
mentioned Belkin and
my favorite friends Mophie
I look forward to all the third-party things that come out of this announcement because that's always something that's so exciting to see what people
Take away from the event and then in return
Create something that they think that we need for these devices that are missing. I mean like look
How frayed this is all three devices charging at the same time
So here's a quick look at what is making everything work right here. We have the infrared camera
We have a flood illuminator a proximity sensor an ambient light sensor speaker microphone
Seven megapixel camera and a dot projector so with all of that built in to the new front-facing camera this gives us so many more
possibilities animated emojis
Obviously extremely important just when you thought you've seen it all you haven't so you can pick your emoji
And then you can hit record in
IMessage you can record your message as it face tracks your face to the emoji
And then you can send as your friend
I mean honestly you guys better believe I'm gonna be posting these all the time another thing they announced is the new Apple TV 4k
HDR the 4k HDR is going to give you such a clearer and brighter image
I loved seeing these side-by-side
Comparison photos because you can really see the difference between the 4k and the 4k HDR
The colors are brighter the blacks are darker
and it's just an overall better image so the biggest problem is the
Content there hasn't been that much content available for 4k and HDR quality, so now a lot more platforms are supporting it
There's a bunch of movies and shows on Netflix
Now that support this and I'm Alan mentioned Netflix because I've actually seen it firsthand
They also mentioned Hulu and ESPN and other live streaming sports
But I can only speak to Netflix because I've seen that firsthand on my lg wallpaper TV one
More thing in this video the Apple watch Series 3 looks absolutely amazing
I'll be making a full video on this guy here very shortly
But the biggest highlighting feature of the Apple watch series 3 is that now supports cellular
So you won't need your phone at all you can leave the house
And you can stream all of your music text messages make calls all without having your iPhone
I got a chance to check out the new black ceramic which looks really beautiful
I'm probably gonna go with the white ceramic again
So that's just sort of a quick overview of the event and some things that I saw today
I would love to hear what you guys think of everything
Did you watch the event are you going to watch it?
Judging by some of the things that you might have seen in my video today or what you've read online or during the keynote let
Me know in the comments below what you guys think are you going to get one? Are you going to wait?
Why why not what phone?
Do you have right now tell me all of the things and I look forward to chatting with you guys in the comments I also
Have some more iPhone videos coming out very very shortly. I just haven't had time to edit so stay tuned
I'll see you guys later. Bye